i'd have to say it would be a wonderful
way to travel in a sidecar
as the iconic harry potter film
franchise was closing in on its climax
the set provided plenty of pulse racing
stunts and heartfelt send-offs
today we're covering the must-know
moments from the deathly hallows part
one
how did they pull off the seven harry's
scene what was the final day on set like
i was so upset on the last day i really
was
everyone was
of the deathly hallows part one takes
place in the real world
or the muggle world for you wizards out
there and in order to pull that off the
production found itself filming
all over the uk and having the cast
perform in these very real
environments but some sequences were a
little too dangerous for actors to do
themselves
that was the case for harry's dangerous
ride with hagrid to the weasley house
while daniel radcliffe was in the
sidecar for a shot or two the rest of
the time
it was his stunt double mark maylie i'm
yet to travel more than about
three meters in it but those three
meters were some of the funnest i've
ever had
seven identical motorbikes were built
for different stunts in the scene
including for flying flipping upside
down crashing into the water for the
landing and traveling as fast as 40
miles per hour
in the actual liverpool queensbury
tunnel even though radcliffe missed out
on these stunts first hand
he found the bright side in being
represented by melee
and also a plus side of having mark um w
is his legendary for having a very very
nice bump
the location for the set of godric's
hollow was dictated largely by an actual
cedar tree production designer stuart
craig found the tree in the garden at
the legendary pinewood studios
and built the tiny town with it in mind
using it as the centerpiece of the
graveyard
the crew also did quite a number on
resident bethilda bagshot's creepy home
lining the rooms with dusty boxes
clothes and even making books that the
character had written herself
inside bethilda bagshot's home daniel
radcliffe did his own stunts when taking
on voldemort's pet snake nagini
to give daniel the experience of being
attacked by cgi nagini
the stunt coordinator greg powell used a
pole with a boxing glove tied to the end
to poke and push radcliffe we've had
some crazy things
fill in for whatever the creature's
supposed to be but on one take powell
went a little overboard and
ended up giving radcliffe a fat lip when
the chair he was using as a shield
hit him in the face radcliffe however
took the minor injury in stride
so i had a fat lip for about a day but
it's it's really calmed down so i'm
feeling pretty good which is good
because i've got a photo
on sunday when it comes to filming in
real world locations piccadilly circus
in london is apparently a pretty big
deal
you do have to watch the movie where we
shut down pink philly circle for the
first time in 32 years
radcliffe rupert grint and emma watson
walked through the world famous site
surrounded by an insane
500 extras the all-night cafe where the
trio does battle with voldemort
loyalists
has a real world easter egg of its own
the crew put up a poster of equus a
stage play daniel radcliffe was starring
in at the time
placing the house elves dobby and
creature in the same space as the actors
required a collaboration of onset
stand-ins
actors who voiced the elves and
eventually cgi of the house elves
themselves
he's creature but i'm better stand-ins
diane gibbons and mindy joe hall
worked with the other actors on set with
their performances used as references by
the vfx team to create the final
sequences with the real dobby and
creature
actor simon mcburney and toby jones
ultimately voiced the house elves
with toby jones even coming on set for
dobby's emotional
final scene i want to bury him properly
without magic
with a crazy 261 shooting days on the
deathly hallows production the cast and
longtime friends had to find ways to
keep things fresh on such a long
shoot daniel radcliffe and rupert grint
opted to invent their own game with mini
table tennis paddles
hilariously dubbed danger ball for the
second ever but first outdoors
danger ball 2009 champion clips rupert
grint managed to find time to goof off
on set as well
grint and his off-screen twin brothers
oliver and james phelps could usually be
found messing around
on segways and sneaking into the studio
at night we've actually been kind of
riding our bikes all through the set and
before filming rapt rupert the phelps
twins and draco malfoy
actor tom felton got a chance to go
golfing together
though some were definitely worse than
others he's not
a very good girlfriend actually things
got a lot more competitive
during the chase in the woods scene
where ron harry and hermione are on the
run from death eaters
it wasn't long at all before the trio
were treating each take like a race
they're all going to say to the fastest
i am demo said emma probably didn't
she's wrong i'm fast it got so
competitive that director david yates
had to remind them that the most
important thing was what was best for
the film
and not who was the fastest but daniel
was more than happy to settle it once
and for all at a later date
call it red carpet next premiere we'll
do i'll have a race man make it 100
yards i'll do it
when it came time to do harry and
hermione's steamy kiss
ron wasn't actually there to see his own
horcrux-induced vision
the intimate scene required that both
daniel and emma be topless and covered
in silver paint
so in order to make the two as
comfortable as possible everyone who
didn't need to be on set for it
wasn't including rupert grint watson
confirmed the decision saying
they did yes it was a closed set and it
was awkward enough without having tons
of people come and watch
the first of the original cast to rap
for good was fittingly
the dursleys this isn't just goodbye boy
is it
this is farewell fiona shaw richard
griffiths and harry melling
were the first along with radcliff to
film for the harry potter series 10
years prior in the sorcerer's stone
or philosopher's stone depending on
where you are in the world
in the time since the family's
relationship had evolved off-screen as
well with radcliffe and griffiths acting
together in a stage play
and melling and shaw doing the same
while the epilogue from part two was the
final scene it was not the last thing
that was filmed the final day of filming
was done at leaves done studios the same
place where they started on the first
film
10 years before it's basic back has been
reserved for me
so uh that's what i have to do today
after the final shot which had harry ron
and hermione leaping to escape the
ministry of magic
the crew surprised them with a heartfelt
video chronicling the past 200 plus days
on the production
i've loved every minute and thank you
all very very much daniel radcliffe
really got a chance to show off his
acting chops when he was tasked with
playing
seven versions of harry that were being
impersonated by seven
different characters this is the most
complicated scene in the world
in order to pull this off radcliffe was
coached by each actor on their
character's mannerisms and movements
it was really fun it's bloody confusing
though he managed to impress not only
the actors but
david yates as well dan plays women
really well actually
while radcliffe pulled them all off
splendidly he did take to some
quicker than others specifically emma
watson's hermione
harry your eyesight really is awful
often it's the details that really
elevate a film to the next level
and the deathly hallows was no different
these key artistic decisions and
contributions came from not only the
crew but even the talented cast as well
magical tents had been introduced in the
goblet of fire and in the deathly
hallows part one they came back in a big
way
set decorator stephanie mcmillan and
production designer stuart craig
designed a
gorgeous magical tent for the setting of
bill weasley and
fleur delacour's wedding you know
they've got the gorgeous the lights that
hover and the
tables look it is definitely a french
influence in stark contrast to the grand
purple wedding tent is the tiny plain
tent harry ron and hermione travel with
for the bulk of the film
[Music]
yeah i'm still here mcmillan and craig's
aim was to make it look
almost identical to the one in the
goblet of fire at least on the outside
it's amazing how much yeah richness and
interest you can get out of a
couple of sheets of canvas basically
actor warwick davis has played more than
one character during his time on the
harry potter films and the one role that
he is probably least recognizable in is
griphook the goblin
chief mold maker led a team of artists
that work together to give davis his
goblin face
each piece of the prosthetic mask had to
be carefully placed on
one at a time in a process that took
about four hours to apply and another
hour to remove
[Music]
the prosthetic mask and accompanying
contacts made it so difficult to see
that every goblin actor including davis
required a chaperone to get around the
set
hello ready for the office talented
actor ivana lynch who portrayed the
peculiar luna lovegood
it's a charm actually
keeps away the nargles was well known
around the production for making
artistic contributions to her character
but those contributions extended to the
set itself when she inspired the design
of the lovegood house
lynch created drawings of magical beasts
in the style of luna herself which were
used as a reference for the paintings
that ultimately covered every inch of
the love good home
but evanna lynch made sure not to ignore
her beloved character
inventing the dance luna and her father
perform at bill weasley and fleur
delacour's wedding she's so in touch
with her spirit that
she's not really affected by other
people hopefully someday daniel
radcliffe and rupert grint will make an
official rule book for danger ball
so we can all play i haven't really
thought about it we've still got a long
way to go yet on this one
and we would have done anything to be
with the cast and crew on the final day
of filming
the tears would have been flowing for
sure what was your favorite behind the
scenes fact
you